hasta ahora son dos miembros del
gabinete que le han renunciado a don
otra vez y de voz secretaria de
educación y él en sao secretaria de
transporte
elaine chau es además la esposa de mitch
mcconnell el jefe el líder republicano
en el senado además pues fuentes
internas de la casa blanca dicen que se
viene también una ola de renuncias de
altos funcionarios esto después de que
se conociera que una policía un policía
del capitolio murió tras los ataques de
simpatizantes de trump cuando se toman
el capitolio crece entonces la voz de
protesta tanto y de demócratas y
republicanos para que donald trump deje
la casa blanca para que renuncie a su
cargo
nancy pelosi demócrata la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes además ha
dicho que si el vicepresidente mike
pence que ha dicho que no está dispuesto
a implementar la enmienda 25 no hace
precisamente eso entonces nancy pelosi
empezará nuevamente un proceso
de impeachment muchos senadores muchos
representantes a la cámara estarían de
acuerdo con este proceso de impeachment
a esto se le suma también pues el
llamado que le hace el wall street
journal un medio conservador republicano
para que don otro deje la casa blanca
antes de que se tenga que afrontar y
hacerle frente a un segundo proceso de
impeachment cristóbal en medio de toda
esta polémica existe la posibilidad de
que el presidente se auto perdone como
lo ha sugerido en el pasado
pues desde que perdió la elección el 3
de noviembre de nosotros viene
sugiriendo eso a sus asesores más
cercanos y nuevamente vuelven fuentes a
decir que trump lo está considerando
recordemos que trump ya ha perdonado a
michael flynn a su ex jefe de campaña
por maná fort y a su asesor
roger stone estaba considerando también
perdones para su familia lo que pasa es
que con este perdón presidencial
donald trump pues se exonera de crímenes
federales sin embargo esto no lo exonera
de crímenes estatales de investigaciones
y acusaciones por ejemplo que tiene en
nueva york entre otros estados pero le
quiero comentar también una orden
ejecutiva que dio el presidente saliente
de donald trump cuando las protestas a
black lives
él dijo que las personas que pues
dañarán edificios públicos iban a tener
que enfrentar 10 años de cárcel si esto
lo aplica a sus simpatizantes
posiblemente se quedaría sin su base
política